MARTIN OMANDER: I love
building APIs on Cloud Run,
because it gives me
autoscaling and I only
pay when my code is
handling a request.
But sometimes I
write full web apps,
which contain both a server
API and client assets,
like HTML files.
Firebase hosting
is a great option
for serving those static assets,
as it includes a global CDN.
But you can also
use Cloud Run itself
if you don't mind
going without a CDN.
Simply tell your web application
framework in your code
that a particular
directory contains
static files to be served
to the client if requested.
Why would you do this?
Well, it simplifies
coding, as you
don't have to deal with
CORS when JavaScript and API
calls are in the same domain.
It simplifies deployments, as
the full web app is deployed
within a single container.
I use this approach for
company internal web apps,
where ease of coding
and ease of deployment
are more important than
global scalability.
Happy coding.